welcome to this video playing do demo 05
from from Turkey I know knows Turkish
flag at least so aha we get the g6
Bishop g4 line yeah here White has a
number of decent setups it's nothing
brilliant for white but also quite okay
now here black often takes on a three
no then after the capture white has a
half-open e file which can prove to be a
very useful I wonder why he's taking
here so long as that that's actually the
main set up that white has against this
opening
no I can take you can play 97 or g6 okay
yeah this is very important to get in d5
p.m. mmm interesting is however I can
also go Bishop 2843 here now i'm not
sure i might want bishop on g2 phone
further support of the deep on
gasps more dogs barking the loudest song
what's the name a very small dog outside
outside my apartment here barking okay
or he's taking lots of time here so we
probably finally have found the player
that's slower than me he's not doing any
commentary though very likely at least
okay so some more support to d5 and
normal setup would be Bishop e3 to d4 so
going to initiate that not really
threatening here on them on the air the
air porn I can go a three before might
might be good one problem for blankets
that he'll Exim direct play he has no
one real active idea yeah something like
that but justice just weakening himself
let's let's not be too quick here I can
also prepare this a bit more wow really
this looks very strange before night
Queen a six mo
i also have bishop everyone here
before Queen 86 bishop f1 this looks
this looks totally absolutely terrible
and this looks very weird yeah it takes
root chicks I mean this is Queen Queen B
seven are the only move or can i play do
I have some stronger some stronger
things even a guess not now that is it
is okay it is okay okay takes rook takes
Queen b7 look at seven Queen before I
have rugae for winning the night I guess
okay so he just down retreats with the
Queen I can take with the pawn or I
could take with the night as well now
taking with the night it's not helping
that much
yeah maybe here after Knight b6 son he
can still continue this it's not not
completely completely lost so back to g2
not sure yeah I guess so just keeping
stuff together maybe going Queen d3r ok
five yeah
have the same maybe 94 as this is this a
bad trade
hmm
I'm not quite sure how to how to play
him maybe this in drew a say no you can
take the form
you know it's surprisingly surprisingly
difficult
okay and that's 96 moves like that at
least this is what I thought beforehand
can I take on d5 even hmm time warning
I'm you need to slow today and why my mi
mi material donor I cannot check came
this is at least easy to blame check I
not it's also winning but i think i
think i blundered a child under the PSM
they could have taken on my queen black
resins i miscounted i miscounted pieces
him yeah and i really i really wonder
what did i do wrong here I think yeah I
think I know I see what I were looked I
need to take with the night and after
here I don't need to retreat a half
night a seven yeah and this is winning
really this is this is a flat win the
rookie is singing and he has no he has
no one to move really just just this
year but this is terrible I look or be
five or whatever I don't I don't lose
the the palm back this was my my prom I
thought I needed to go back and this
isn't isn't so great and yeah that's not
really easy absolutely not went here
question will move promptly and this no
yeah I really lost the thread here Jim
and this is probably just a blunt layer
I can go Quincy five but this this
should lose I mean my pro tempore sure I
saw this but here i miscounted I'm
really a piece down so very lucky he
could have just done that just he didn't
he played this and no no why this
winning quite check not clearly yeah
that was a very lucky game it was it was
very it was very one-sided up to here
but then then I lost the threat here not
be five this much better i forgot about
97 and this is also the logical
consequence we call what blanket each it
really is bad yeah b5 and and this is a
very weird way to play putting yourself
into this
into this awkward situation yeah but I
must I must play this really this is
winning very easily okay God got to be
lucky once in a while thanks for
watching